but as far as my position and my role
I've got an incredibly important
responsibility to people as the chantix
checker to provide stability in these
challenging times and I take a very
simple view of life which is it's my
country right or wrong and I intend to
fulfill my responsibilities to the
country
I don't resolve from any of the concerns
I expressed during the campaign but I
fully accept the result of the
referendum and will do everything I can
to make it work for Britain it is
inevitable after Thursday's vote the
Britain's economy is going to have to
adjust to the new situation we find
ourselves in I said we had to fix the
roof so that we were prepared for
whatever the future held and thank
goodness we did as a result our economy
is about as strong as it could be to
confront the challenge our country now
faces I want to reassure the British
people and the global community that
Britain is ready to confront what the
future holds for us from a position of
strength that is because in the last six
years the government and the British
people have worked hard to rebuild the
British economy we've worked
systematically through a plan that today
means Britain has the strongest major
advanced economy in the world growth has
been robust the employment rate is at a
record high the capital requirements for
banks are ten times what they were and
the budget deficit has been brought down
from 11% of our national income and was
forecast to be below 3% this year